a massive show of force tanks
artillery more than one hundred thousand
russian troops the u.s military says
this is now a strong enough force to
take over the country of ukraine on
monday the u.n security council will put
the issue front and center with the u.s
ambassador saying she will try to make
russia feel isolated in the world our
voices are unified in calling for
the russians to explain themselves we're
we're going to go in the room prepared
to listen uh to them but we're we're not
going to be distracted by their
propaganda and the ukrainian ambassador
to the us is hoping to rally the
international community as well with a
warning
if
ukraine will be further attacked by
russia of course they will not stop in
india after ukraine but with russia able
to veto any action at the u.n this is
likely to be more theater than a
solution but one prominent u.s senator
has a new suggestion saying the u.s
can't give in to russia's demands that
ukraine will not join nato but ukraine
can but it's his decision to make if he
decides that the future membership if
there's to be one in nato for ukraine
and the question of russian occupation
of ukraine are two things to put on the
table
i think we may move toward a solution to
this this week the u.s senate is
expected to take up a bill that would
spell out severe consequences if russia
acts which would include sanctions which
would include more military assistance
which would include helping them to
fight back against the cyber attacks
that the russians continue
to use against ukraine and also to help
on the disinformation campaign that
russia is actively involved in to try to
destabilize the zelinski government
but the biden administration wants to
hold off on sanctions as a deterrent
hoping that the threat of freezing
russia out of the international banking
system is enough to stop any military
action which russia says it has no
intention of taking
in kiev on sunday a show of gratitude
ukrainians take to the streets to send a
message that they appreciate the support
even as many hope they won't need it
patty culhane al jazeera washington